a lot of you out there want to get into
data science because you fundamentally
understand how data
and artificial intelligence are going to
impact our world
maybe you have a passion for math or for
programming or for data in general
but in reality i know there's one real
reason why a lot of you are in this
space
and it's for that sweet sweet cash so in
the time i've been involved in data
science
i've made a number of fairly significant
moves up in the compensation department
so i wanted to share with you guys some
insights i have
on how to move up that ladder before we
get started just a few disclaimers
first and foremost i am not a licensed
or professional career advisor
so as such this video should just be
taken to give you some helpful food for
thought
and maybe hopefully for entertainment
purposes as well
secondly this discussion is strictly
about jobs and
industry now personally my base of data
science knowledge
has been used to generate some other
sources of revenue
specifically from this youtube channel
as well as from cryptocurrency trading
but those are completely outside of the
scope of this video
however even if you're not a data
scientist by profession yourself
i think most of these things will work
for you too
that also means that nothing in here is
a get rich quick scheme
so if that's the kind of thing that
you're looking for this probably isn't
the video for you
think of the stuff in here as more of a
get rich slow scheme if that helps
so before i start talking about
everybody's favorite topic
aka money just a few usual asks
number one smash the like button to this
video for the youtube algorithm
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell
that way youtube notifies you whenever i
upload a video
and then if you guys would be willing to
pitch in to support my channel
i'll have links in the description of
this video to my paypal account
as well as crypto wallet addresses all
right so i'm gonna tell the full story
behind
when and where i've personally gotten
raises
and then we're going to circle back at
the end and i'm going to talk about
why i think those happen and some key
takeaways
and i'm going to keep the focus here on
the percentage increases that i've
received
because there's so much variation
globally and regionally in salaries
and at the end of the day the most
important thing is no matter where
you're starting from
that over time you continue to move up
so when i got my first job fresh out of
my master's degree
i had a base salary but i had to wait a
solid year
before i got my first raise and i know
this makes for a pretty long
first year but i think this is pretty
standard with most organizations
when i got my first ever raise it had
been about a year and three months or so
since i'd started
it was time for the company to do annual
compensation adjustments
and so that first raise amounted to five
percent
not bad covers the loss of the
purchasing power of your money to
inflation
all that good stuff unfortunately though
with that organization
another year came around and i'd
received a promotion and all that jazz
but due to a variety of external
circumstances
the company was not able to perform more
compensation adjustments
so somewhere between the two and a half
and three year mark
i made the decision to leave the company
and trust me when i say
that was not an easy decision because i
absolutely
loved the people there and the work i
was doing and i had learned a lot during
my time there
in my case there were some personal
reasons for it too
but yes the money thing was definitely a
significant factor in my decision
now when i was leaving companies i asked
my new organization for an adjustment of
about
25 upwards to be totally fair
that was an incredibly tall ask and no
they did not grant that
they ended up coming back to me with an
offer to give me a 15
adjustment and we ended up negotiating
and meeting in the middle with a 19
adjustment that brought me through some
work that i was doing on a longer term
contract basis with a specific sponsor
and that work lasted about 18 months at
almost exactly the one year mark along
the way
i was given a bump of about 5.5 percent
now just to give some context on a
timeline here
this was shortly after i'd started my
youtube channel it was brand new
i was just getting it off the ground and
i am going to circle back to that
because that's going to be relevant
later
so a few months later that contract work
came to a close
and i came back to a full-time position
within my hiring organization
that came with a promotion shortly
thereafter
and that promotion came with an 11.5
percent raise or so
and then just recently it came time to
do a second round of annual compensation
adjustments
which for me came out to about an
additional nine percent
so it's been now almost five years since
i finished my master's degree
and entered the professional world full
time
excluding various consulting gigs that i
was doing pretty consistently throughout
grad school
and since then i've been fortunate
enough to receive what i think
pretty much anybody would consider to be
generous which is about a
60 percent movement upward in salary
now in fairness if we were trying to
represent how much i know
now and how much value i can provide to
organizations
as opposed to five years ago the
difference between them would be many
times greater than 60 percent
but that's not the point and it's
impossible to create a fair true
compensation structure based on that
and so i'm now going to provide five
insights into how exactly
i think i was able to move up so fast
the first point is that moving up in
salary
starts before you even have your first
full-time job with a salary
it starts all the way back in college
let's think about this
all the way back with the economic
reason why you get paid a salary in the
first place
and essentially it's because you provide
surplus
economic value to an organization i get
that that's a little bit simplistic
in many cases but the philosophical
underpinnings of that are
true the more value that you're able to
provide an
organization the better i recommend
watching my video
all about how to break into data science
to best
set yourself up because really
everything there applies to this
discussion about salary
i think the most important point in this
salary discussion is
if you're coming from previous work
experience whether that's an internship
or even unpaid work if it has to be that
that's going to go a long way when i was
in grad school i did paid teaching
an unpaid research gig for some
connections that i knew who needed
some help a paid internship
working as a consultant also and then a
separate
unpaid consulting gig for an outside
organization
and except for the teaching job i landed
every single
one of those jobs just through my
network
because either i knew people who needed
help
or those people who i knew knew somebody
else who needed help
and i think having some of that prior
experience under my belt
really helped me get into my first job
at at least a decent starting point or
more than it would have been otherwise
now the second takeaway here is that
you're not necessarily guaranteed to get
a raise
if you don't ask for one when you do
decide to ask for a raise
there's one of a couple different ways
that you should try to frame it
one approach is that you may be
underpaid relative to the general market
so for example it could be data
scientists in your region
with the same level of experience
typically make 100k on average
you find that out through doing your own
research but maybe you only make
75k that may be a mistake on your
company's part
and that may be grounds for an
adjustment then the other approach
is very clearly with numbers
demonstrating that you provide
way more value to the organization than
you're taking
out from them in the form of
compensation but of course be reasonable
about
it i mean don't ask for a 30 movement
upward while your company is
restructuring and going through layoffs
or something like that
but you never know ask and you just
might receive
sometimes it doesn't work out though and
that's going to bring me to my next
point
which is that yeah sometimes it is
appropriate to switch jobs
so there's a bit of a balancing act to
this one because if you go and you
switch
jobs every year or every year and a half
it is going to look like a major red
flag after a while
and it's going to make companies start
to get a little hesitant to invest in
you
having said that it's well known that
changing jobs will typically give you
some of the biggest boosts in salary
that you're ever going to get
so this is from an article from
marketwatch and they've got a cpa and a
tax expert who stated that
consistently remaining employed at
companies for longer than two years
can decrease your lifetime earnings by
as much as fifty percent
but then it's well known that annual
raises are typically around three
percent or so
but then he estimates changing jobs
whenever you do it
will get you a 10 to 20 percent increase
at the end of the day there's a lot more
that goes into deciding do you stay or
do you go
than just the cash alone but just know
what you're signing up for
if you're intending to stay at a company
for the long haul
now the next point here is when you're
actually getting hired in
negotiate and ask for more money right
then
because there's no better time to do so
so there's a little bit of a game that
typically gets played between hr
professionals and
job seekers in the sense that when they
give you their first
offer letter they're typically gonna
lowball you a little bit
and if you think about it you can't
really blame them
because what happens is so many people
once they receive a job offer
they're going to counter offer that well
if you suppose
a certain percentage of people don't
counter offer
well the company is able to go a little
bit lower with them
and the company has just saved
themselves a considerable amount of
money
don't be part of that percentage that
doesn't ask for more
now obviously be polite and be
reasonable and measured about it
ask them if there's some wiggle room for
some adjustment on your salary
come prepared with some statistics and
some market research
on how much data scientists in your area
with your level of experience typically
make
and if you're not a jerk about it you're
not gonna lose your original
offer trust me and you might just set
yourself up with more money then
which is gonna get compounded years in
the future in the form of raises
so your more money gets turned into more
more money
then the last takeaway here is probably
the most important one of all of them
and it's to build a network and a real
public presence
as i stated earlier in this video
literally
almost every single professional
opportunity i've
ever come upon came because i knew
somebody through my network
not because i blew people away with some
amazing project or portfolio or
something
so networking can get you in the door
and it can open up
other doors in the future once you get
some experience under your belt
you can take this a step further and so
this is partly speculation on my part
i don't know this to a hundred percent
certainty
but i don't think i would have done as
well for myself in the last couple years
in the money department
if i didn't have this youtube channel
where i contribute to things in the body
of data science knowledge out there
because i feel i have something to add
to it
people can look at it this way okay this
guy has
over 5000 subscribers located all around
the globe
more than 5000 people care what he has
to say i guess he must be legit
now i'm not saying any of this to put
myself on a pedestal
at all because i think way more people
can contribute in public forums like
youtube
and don't even realize it there are
plenty of options out there other than
just
youtube you can start writing blog
articles on medium
you can become a regular contributor at
places like github or stack overflow
or you could even build up your network
on linkedin and post there regularly
there's tons of things that you can do
to put yourself out there
you just need to figure out what makes
the most sense for you
i will end this one with a word of
caution though
be careful and don't do anything that'll
get you in trouble
there's a well-known youtuber tech lead
who got fired from facebook
for his youtube channel so when in doubt
talk to your boss
over communicate so that's my story
along with
what i think has stood out and been
successful for me
another word of caution that i'll try to
leave you with here is
just be careful as you chase higher
salaries
there's a lot of other potentially
competing interests
to pay attention to as well things like
benefits paid time off
work life balance in general just me
personally
i know a lot of really miserable people
who make a whole lot of money
but if you're in data science there's
plenty of ways out there to make money
and if you're not in data science try
some of these things anyway
i think they'll help you so thanks for
watching this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and then leave me a comment down below
let me know how you made more money
professionally yourself
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data